you know I never I never saw this coming
I I love it
I'm I'm taken aback by it every day now
in my life I get an email that's quite
powerful whether it's somebody trying to
survive cancer and watching my show or
somebody starting a career literally
literally no joke no hyperbole walking
out of my building today my doorman
stops me hey mr. B you know it's all
very professional on the Upper East Side
could I show you something showed me a
quote that I said who kind of went like
the the guy or gal that grows up cooking
with their grandmother in the kitchen is
always gonna beat the person that goes
to culinary school you know it's kind of
the essence of doing it he said that
that quote inspired his friend and
changed that person's life and is now at
Iran eclis one of the great culinary
schools and has a profession it's kind
of funny but you know it's just crazy I
mean I I wish it on all of you I wish it
on all of you to know that even though
you're going after your own
self-interests by proxy by sawdust by
process you're bringing so much good in
the world
it's an incredibly intoxicating